What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
We can't be more excited to be launching
Our very own table tennis racket
The Pongfinity Sensei!
And to celebrate the launch
We have made an exclusive edition of 100 numbered rackets
And today we'll be glueing and trying them out ourselves!
So for example, if you are the fifth person to make an order
You'll get this number 5 racket
So be fast!
Let's start off with the first two rackets
This is the the one!
The world's most valuable Pongfinity racket
This is the number one!
Let's start glueing!
The glueing has begun!
This is going to be a long day!
Yes!
Let it dry!
So the first ever Pongfinity racket being cut!
Voilá!
That is the first red rubber
There
Number one!
Yea
Edge tape
That’s ready!
The world’s first Pongfinity racket
Good touch!
Feels good in the hand
Let’s test them out!
Let’s try one backhand
Ok
See how this works
I have no idea
Okay?
It works!
Or?
Does it?
Yeah it’s okay!
Around the net!
There we have it!
It works
I mean, not bad!
Number one racket!
Number one
Always number one
Always number two?
You were number two in that rally Otto!
But the racket, it has really good control a good spin
So it’s suitable for any developing player
One out of one hundred
The very first racket
Who will get this?
Pause the video
Go quickly to pongfinity.store to buy it
And then come back to watch the video!
Number one
In a few years this might actually be worth something
Who knows?
-Yea, you never know!
It's like a collectable item
Whoever gets this
Send us a message!
The first package done!
So racket number one
And two, ready to be shipped to the world!
Two percent done, 98 to go!
I like glueing table tennis rubbers
Racket number four
I’ll give it a magic kiss
Now nobody wants it anymore
Perfect!
Yea!
Racket number three!
Half long
Somebody’s gonna get a broken racket
Ooohh! That was dodgy!
Passed the half-long check!
Number three and four!
We are progressing!
Now we’re going to speed things up
We’re going to do 10 rackets at a time
It was about 2,5 years ago
When we started thinking about making our own racket
Feels super exciting to
actually get this launched now
And have everything ready!
Ok, so the racket number six
Gets six forehand loops!
Really?
Let's pack it up!
But... you should have got 5 blocks?
Actually you did get 5 blocks!
I did get!
- That's true!
Whoever gets number ten
They'll have a secret signature under [the rubber]
Otto is vibing with racket number?
Thirteen!
My favorite number!
No wonder it had good vibes!
Yea!
Number 13 gets a cartwheel
It’s very suitable for cartwheel shots, this one
This is going to take soooo long!
It's 5 PM currently
And I really can't see
that we'd be done with this before midnight
Nineteen is done!
Very good footwork Miikka
Thanks!
36!
1.9 millimeter thick
We have the ITTF approval
So this is actually a rubber that
you can use officially in any tournament
Hour 8 of glueing table tennis rackets
We have 46 [rackets] ready
Almost a hundred [rubbers]
Do you guys have any suggestions
on what we could do with these?
Let us know in the comments!
Certificates authorized!
Let's test these rackets
The first around the net
Really good for around the nets as well!
50!
Okay
That means we are halfway
through this whole process
And it's almost midnight
Whoever gets number 50
You'll also get...
A Pongfinity racket case!
So you can keep your racket here
That's highly recommended
to get for your racket
Very nice quality!
So whoever gets the number 50
You'll get it [the racket case] for free!
51 is of course the number
of the behind the back shot
55 and 56
The Pongfinity bounce challenge
Aaah that's nice!
One!
- Very good one!
Two!
- Nice!
Three!
Noooo!
I don't know why I twiddled!
It's past midnight
We have been glueing for 13 hours...
The remaining blades
And the remaining rubbers
Let's do this!
We wanted to have the colors of our logo
So that's why we went for black and red
And we thought this looked really cool
with the black surface
And with the red little stripe going through
The silver lens looks so nice there!
Yea
And then also underneath
The Pongfinity text and the logo
I'm done!
Are you going to head home now?
Yes!
Nice! You have earned it!
It's quite funny you can already hear
the birds starting to sing outside
Because it's 3 AM
The birds are waking up
We also have to thank everybody
who has helped us with this
Everything from the design to the rubbers
And everything [else] so...
Big thanks to all of you have been with us
in making this possible
And of course
All you viewers
That's pretty much the whole reason why this
- in the first place
Is even possible that we actually launched this
And it feels so nice for ourselves
It's been sort of a dream for us
to make an own racket
At some point
And to see it concretely now ahead of us
Is really, really cool
So thank you for that!
This is the final one!
One hundred!
Yea I think we'll keep this one [racket number 100]
As a memory of this crazy idea
It's surprising how much time it
actually takes to make 100 rackets
98!
99!
100!
Done!
Ok, it's 4 AM
We have the rackets ready
We still need to test the last 20
Good around the net with 84!
Good spin!
Don’t give me there!
So, that was almost 20 hours of making
our own table tennis racket
What a crazy project!
But we are really happy how it turned out to be
Hope you enjoy it as much as we do!
Yea!
Now, it's time to go sleep!
And you, go to pongfinity.store to get your racket!
Until next time!